ab zu KFC
hot Wings bucket ich hätte gerne einen
Hot Wings bucket mit Coleslaw Security
back
KFC Kentucky Fried Chicken die
wahrscheinlich bekannteste Chicken Wings
Fast Food Kette der Welt das Rezept das
der Legende nach der Körner irgendwann
mal in Kentucky erfunden hat ist
wirklich um die ganze Welt bekannt und
sie rühmen sich damit dass es ein
Geheimrezept ist deshalb wird die
heutige Challenge dass du gut wie es
geht zu Hause nachzumachen besonders
schwierig sag mal so viel ich habe mich
gut vorbereitet ich habe mich natürlich
nicht für irgendein KFC Produkt
entschieden sondern für die Hot Wings
das meiner Meinung nach legendärste
Produkt das KFC ihm Angebot hat das hat
für mich so Sehnsüchte ausgelöst als ich
so 14 15 war und mich nach Amerika
geträumt und dann wollte ich so gar
keine ich würde auch so ein wackelt für
mich außerdem haben wir noch den KFC
coal den man auch auf der ganzen Welt
kennt auch der sollte nicht ganz leicht
nachzumachen sein aber wir kriegen das
schon hin was macht hot Wings aus für
mich ganz eindeutig diese
knusprige Panade keine Ahnung was das
ist ich dachte früher immer das ist
Cornflakes sind aber wenn man sich es
genauer anschaut ist es auf jeden Fall
nicht und die Besonderheit ist natürlich
auch der Spice also die sind nicht super
scharf wenn jemand der gerne scharf ist
aber die haben trotzdem so ein
besonderes Schärfe level was aber eine
perfekte geschmacksschärfe ist also
nicht so das ist weh tut sondern einfach
so und schmeckt die Schärfe ich probiere
einfach mal um die Geschmacksknospen zu
erinnern an dieses wundersame Produkt
schicken knusprige Panade es löst sich
perfekt vom Knochen ja so viel Geschmack
so viel Gewürze so viel flavour in so
ein Wing rein zu bekommen ist wirklich
eine Herausforderung der wir uns jetzt
stellen wir fangen an mit dem
Vorbereitungen für Wings und los geht's
wir haben zwei Komponenten einmal den
legendären KFC Coles dafür haben wir
alles hier drüben stehen und natürlich
die Hot Wings ich sage so viel wir
brauchen viele viele Gewürze packen uns
in Handschuh damit wir unser chicken
richtig schön durchkneten können und
geben einfach alle Zutaten hinein
erstmal ein halber Liter Buttermilch
dann kommt der weiße Pfeffer
Knoblauchpulver Knoblauchpulver ist
einfach auch so ein Geschmack Booster
ein richtiger Geschmacksmuster ist auch
Geschmacksverstärker MSP viele Leute
haben sehr viele Angst davor ich sag so
viel eigentlich nicht nötig könnt ihr
euch was zu anschauen so Shinys R Us und
so es gibt eigentlich zu viele
Vorurteile in Deutschland dagegen man
sollte natürlich trotzdem genießen dann
Salz und zu guter Letzt Chili Paprika
die kneten das Ganze einmal schön durch
ist alles verbunden ist ihr denkt
vielleicht das sind schon viele Gewürze
es kommen noch mal zehn dran wenn wir
den trockenen Teil machen deshalb bleibt
dran um zu sehen wie das ganze
funktioniert das lassen wir jetzt
erstmal stehen jetzt kümmern wir uns um
den Coleslaw den wir am besten auch über
Nacht marinieren lassen weil wie bei
jedem Coleslaw zieht das ganze noch ein
bisschen mehr durch wir machen das jetzt
die Zutaten für unseren natürlich Cole
also Kohl das hier ist ein Kohlkopf dann
habe ich hier drei Möhren und zwei rote
Zwiebeln einfach dann möglichst fein
schneiden damit man wirklich diesen Look
hinbekommen das geht uns wie immer darum
den Look zu treffen wirklich so wie KFC
am Ende Zeit bei side alles da stehen zu
haben für den Code löschen wir uns als
erstes eine Karotte und schneiden die in
einem Winkel an der Winkel muss so lange
sein wie wir die karottenstifte wollen
zack ich mache das mal mit zwei Karotten
und dann kümmern wir uns um den Rest so
sieht das ganze dann aus perfekte Stifte
aus Karotten und ich glaube die machen
viel für den finalen Look weiter mit
Zwiebel und Kohl die ziehen wir ja auch
einfach durch das ist kein Hexenwerk wir
sehen uns gleich wieder wenn alles
fertig ist zack
fein geschnittener Kohl dazu wir geben
als allererstes ein bisschen Zucker dran
ein bisschen Salz etwas Weißweinessig
Mayonnaise ist nicht weniger
das ganze ey guck dir das mal an das
sieht eins zu eins aus sieht sehr gut
aus damit können wir arbeiten einige
Stunden sind jetzt schon vergangen wir
haben das Chicken eingelegt der Coaster
ist auch mariniert und ich sage euch so
viel ich habe ein gutes Gefühl das wird
richtig lecker aber wenn wir den ganzen
Tag schon so ungesund Essen und uns fast
food selbst machen und gekauftes Fast
Food reinschauen dann wollen wir doch
wenigstens was gesundes trinken und das
gesündeste was man trinken kann es
Wasser aber das schmeckt nach Eistee
danke ab ist die neue Art zu trinken und
soll kein Bier oder einen Softdrink eins
zu eins ersetzen sondern soll dir wieder
mehr Spaß am Wasser trinken oder einfach
eine willkommene Abwechslung sein und
das beste mit dem Code Max panisch bei
ihr von heute bis zum 19 April 10 % auf
das gesamte Sortiment auf die eigens
konzipierte erdflasche setzt ihr euren
Duft und füllt Leitungswasser ein
dadurch schon beiläufig die Umwelt weil
ihr keine PET-Flaschen oder Dosen mehr
verbraucht und ihr landet bei einem
Literpreis von 39 Cent pro Liter ich
glaube es ist wirklich für jeden eine
Geschmacksrichtung dabei es gab schon
erdbeerbalsamico Cherry Cola ich habe
gerade einfach Eistee drauf also
bestimmt ist für dich auch was dabei
sobald ihr den Duft Pott hochzieht
aktiviert er sich und ihr könnt trinken
wenn an dem Aufsatz hier oben trinkt
entsteht ein Sog durch den natürlich das
Wasser hochzieht aber gleichzeitig auch
Luft zirkulieren lassen die dann durch
den Pott bzw am Pot vorbei in eurer
richtzentrum im Rachen kommt und dort
als Geschmack wahrgenommen wird klingt
sehr technisch klingt einmal das ihr
werdet verstehen es schmeckt wirklich
einfach nicht nur noch Wasser ich war
die letzten Tage ein bisschen unterwegs
und konnte die große Flasche nicht
mitnehmen im Handgepäck und ich habe
wirklich gemerkt dass ich weniger trinke
wenn ich die Flasche dabei habe ist das
einfach so ein zeitvertreibling und ich
glaube mehr trinken können wirklich
viele von uns und wenn ihr jetzt Lust
auf mehr habt dann checkt er ab ab und
benutzt meinen Link in der Beschreibung
damit sichert euch 10% Rabattcode Max
pane bis zum 19 weiter geht es mit KFC
und einem gesunden Drink für nebenbei
all diese Gewürze geben wir jetzt in
unser Mehl für die Panade und wir fangen
an mit MSC Geschmacksverstärker noch ein
zweites Mal könnt ihr immer noch
weglassen wenn ihr unbedingt wollt aber
ich glaube das hilft auf jeden Fall um
diesen Geschmack zu erzielen Senfpulver
seltenes Gewürz habe ich bisher auch
noch nicht genutzt Geheimzutat
vielleicht auch ein Stück weit ne das
geht ja darum wirklich herauszukitzeln
was wir brauchen und das hier darf auch
nicht fehlen weißer Pfeffer dann haben
wir hier noch mal Knoblauchgranulat was
wir auch schon in der flüssigen Marinade
hatten Oregano Thymian Ingwer
Paprikapulver das gibt noch ein bisschen
Farbe in die Panade Chilipulver und
normales Salz guckt euch das mal an das
ist schon wirklich ein farbenfrohes
Spektakel was wir hier sehen und wir
haben wirklich unfassbar viele rechts
richtig so wie in so einem Gewürzen
irgendwie ein Gewürzhandel das ganze
verbinden wir jetzt einmal ordentlich
wenn es perfekt verbunden ist können wir
anfangen unser chicken zu panieren bevor
wir das ganze machen wollen wir aber
schon ein paar von diesen
charakteristischen KFC Flakes schaffen
indem wir unsere überschüssige Marinade
in unsere Panade hineintropfen und das
ganze dann ein bisschen umrühren so dass
wirklich schon so diese kleinen
so und jetzt nehmen wir uns wirklich
einzeln die Chicken Wings sind immer
Flaps und Drums also die mit zwei und
einem Knochen geben sich hinein und dann
drücken wir die Panade richtig
ordentlich an so dass wir eine perfekte
Bedeckung haben wenn wir das jetzt
angucken
dann sehen wir auf jeden Fall dass das
gut aussieht
so werde ich das jetzt mit unseren
Chicken Wings machen kann ein bisschen
dauern aber dafür haben wir am Ende ein
wunderbaren bucket
[Musik]
gehst richtig auf in solchen Aufgaben
ich habe no Drop bei sowas habe ich dann
so wirklich den schon fast so ein Zwang
das so gut wie möglich zu machen weil
ich will wirklich dann so im
side-by-side dass du Leute sagen okay
das ist neu ich erinnere mich noch so
ich weiß noch so als du gemacht hast bei
Kolumbien hast du dann auch so dann auch
noch als sie auf Cam waren die ganze
Zeit so weiter gemacht
so meditativ so die Dinger so
nacheinander so Weg zu panieren und
einfach so geile Resultate zu bekommen
schaut sie euch an unsere panierten hot
Wings paniert sind sie frittiert werden
sie jetzt dafür nehmen wir sie einfach
und geben sie in 160 Grad heißes Öl
immer schön vom Körper weg nicht zu
viele auf einmal und einfach frittieren
bis die goldbraun sind die meiste Arbeit
ist getan und es war gar nicht so viel
Arbeit wenn ich ganz ehrlich bin das
Subway Sandwich war ein bisschen
umfangreicher sage ich mal als Projekt
aber so kann man das auf jeden Fall
machen entweder werden sie genau gleich
sein sie werden schlechter sein oder sie
werden besser sein
neun Stück haben wir drin die Backen wir
aus dann kommen die anderen neuen es
wird glaube ich gut schaut euch das mal
an es sieht wirklich sehr gut aus aber
die Marinade haftet leider nicht überall
perfekt an das ist noch nicht das
Ergebnis was ich will ich könnte mir
vorstellen wenn wir die so also quasi
schon mit angedrückter Panade noch mal
in den flüssigen Teig geben und dann
noch mal panieren dann kriegen wir
vielleicht wirklich eine geschlossene
Außenhaut hin die mache ich jetzt so die
anderen neuen probiere ich noch mal mit
dieser Technik und vielleicht kommen wir
dann noch näher ins original weil das
macht mich noch nicht zufrieden ich will
mehr noch mal rein in die Marinade weil
ich glaube ohne dass kann es gar nicht
funktionieren dass das so geschlossen
ist oder es muss da wo es muss aber das
könnte auf dieser Aspekt sein warum das
so brutal schmeckt weil das einfach auch
so viel Panade hat das war auf jeden
Fall nicht in dem
Rezepte drin aber ich glaube das könnte
entscheidender Schritt sein
[Musik]
jetzt haben wir noch den Geschmack der
für uns punkten kann weil wenn das
wirklich nah dran kommt dann bin ich so
halb zufrieden wir richten das ganze mal
schön an und dann sieht es bestimmt
schon gar nicht mehr so schlimm aus hier
sind sie jetzt also und ich bin ganz
ehrlich in der Präsentation von KFC bin
ich doch wieder ganz zufrieden also
natürlich hier auf der Seite meine
Version hier drüben die von KFC wenn wir
uns erstmal den Coleslaw angucken bin
ich ganz ehrlich meiner sieht viel
besser aus und immer guckt bei der KFC
Version ist gefühlt bisschen mehr Wasser
drin und die Soße sage ich einfach mal
ist gelb gefärbt ich könnte mir
vorstellen das liegt ein bisschen an dem
Carotin von den Möhren und dieser hier
zu sehen wie das ist eher so eine helle
Farbe und wir haben sogar noch ein
bisschen getrig das ist die gleiche
Flüssigkeit erhält ein bisschen Sahne
bisschen Zucker dran weil dieser ist auf
jeden Fall sehr sehr süßler
ganz ganz viel Zucker aber auch so ein
sehr sehr prägnanter Kohl Geschmack also
der kommt wirklich sehr krass heraus es
ist noch ein bisschen feiner als hätte
wir gemacht haben jetzt probieren wir
mal unseren saftig
der knack ist auf jeden Fall noch viel
viel mehr vorhanden ne viel frischer
halt geht sehr nah in diese Richtung ist
fehlen die letzten fünf Prozent bin ich
ganz ehrlich so diese industriellen fünf
Prozent und die werden auch in Zukunft
glaube ich bei allem was wir nachmachen
schwer zu holen sein hier ist
wahrscheinlich eine riesen Zutatenliste
dabei Emulgatoren und irgendwas hier
haben wir alles gerade selbst frisch
gekocht dafür ganz ehrlich sehr krass
wenn man länger nicht KFC gegessen hat
und den jetzt bekommen würde
zugeschweißt alles okay wir haben
vielleicht die Rezeptur geändert würde
aber trotzdem sagen das ist so ein
richtig dreckiger cold so also einer der
eigentlich wirklich nur darüber
hinwegtäuscht dass man gerade was
ungesund ist weil auch der Salat selbst
ist ungesund deshalb bin ich sehr
zufrieden die Wings leicht andere Farbe
nach dem Frittieren der ist ein bisschen
kürzer frittiert worden vielleicht wir
sehen hier diese Cluster auf der
Oberfläche haben wir auch hinbekommen
bei uns sind die so ein bisschen feiner
wird brüchiger ja feine mehr so Chips
und hier drauf sind das so Klumpen KFC
ja ja immer noch saftig immer noch
knusprig ich weiß es auf jeden Fall
jetzt mehr zu schätzen das ist wirklich
auch wenn es fast gut ist auf jeden Fall
ein wahnsinnig gut ausgefallenes Produkt
jetzt meine eigenen Wings ihr habt ja
gesehen nicht alle sind so schön wie
dieser hier aber probieren wir
ich sehe auch eine reine Saftigkeit mehr
hähnchengeschmack viel viel viel dafür
krass das ist ein 18 das ist ein zwölf
so ich habe ein paar übrig gelassen viel
größer das ist Fried Chicken das sind
geile Wings aber würde vielleicht sogar
sagen sind nicht richtige hot Wings ihr
habt gesehen was ich da rein geklopft
habe angewürzen die sind nicht so scharf
wie die von KFC das muss man probieren
deswegen ist die Schärfe fehlt was du am
Daumen ist so diese chicken Wing KFC
Ding was wirklich auch auf KFC geprägt
ist das ist dabei das heißt das einzige
was wir hätten machen können wir noch
mehr Schärfe hinzuzufügen ist jetzt ein
Problem was man easy lösen kann das mit
der Panade kann man auch noch weiter
optimieren einfach so vielleicht mit so
einem ganz ganz dicken Flüssigkeit oder
chicken macht definitiv manche Sachen
besser und einige Sachen schlechter als
das andere deshalb ist auch schwer
werden genau ein Gewinner auszumachen
Aspekt komplett eins zu eins nachmachen
hat nicht ganz funktioniert heute
nichtsdestotrotz mega viel gelernt also
alleine was für Sachen in der Panade
drin sind mit irgendwas mit Knoblauch
mit allem drum dran sehr lehrreiches
Video auch für mich ich hoffe euch hat
es vor allem eins unterhalten ich muss
jetzt ganz schnell anfangen zu verteilen
sonst werde ich übelst Fett weil beides
macht auf jeden Fall süchtig schreibt
mal in die Kommentare was wir als
nächstes nachmachen sollen ich gebe mir
heute dafür sieben von zehn würde ich
sagen bis zum nächsten Video ciao
kommt essen